this isn't how it was supposed to happen
on this episode of dudy there's a
flashlight in my underwear please don't
hurt me hell that' have to be a mountain
of pizza to make a smell like
[Music]
that everything thinking be the
say Chad made the world inside your head
better place to
be all you got to do for
me call me
Duty peace on
Earth can it
be years from now perhaps we'll
[Music]
see see the day of
Glory see the day when man of good
willll live in peace live in peace Again
David Bo yeah love Bowie hate Christmas
music oh come on hate it come on dude
hey Chad we're having a really good show
let's have a good show today okay we're
gonna have a good show I always agree
with that hey welcome to dudy welcome
all it is a dudy full day I am your
reigning defending Undisputed uh dudy
episode Champion Will Sasso and I am the
uh longest reigning champion and first
champion of dudes Chad culture thanks
for joining us this is of course dudy
the first and only podcast controlled by
created by an artificial intelligence
that has access to all of Will and I's
personal data uses that data to make
this show yeah of course it does Chad of
course it does but like I said before
okay Chad we're we're we're the show
okay we're dudy it's you and I Chad it's
not it's not but know so much about what
the part yeah we're a part of it that's
right but but also we we we decide we're
we're the guys that Mak let's have a
good show okay all right let's have a
good show today all right with us as
always is lulio it's
lulio and he's a sweet boy he's just in
his seat he's having a rest after eating
some meat immediate breakfast for immedi
boy that's why L is my little friend
give him a kiss right on the mouth I
don't want to ah why wouldn't you want
to he's such a sweetie boy and he looks
at you and he says hey please Uncle Chad
please kiss me on mouth Lully how you
doing today you doing okay yeah I'm okay
it's a pretty good it's going to be hey
Bal that's right Lully it's Christmas
soon you got your Christmas shopping
done I know Christmas shop why would I
do that I'm a dog you got you uh you got
you to on yeah that's right your mama
Molly got me this toque it says Real
Canadian shorts boy that's what she
calls me Real Canadian shorts boy when I
wear shorts during the winter
winter hey that's a disgusting a Chad
are going to look away while you're
coughing and stuff like that what do you
uh what have you been making lately well
I go out I buy panetone and pandoro oh
that's delicious stuff Chad you like
Pandora you like panone what is that
okay well it's Italian we'll get into it
during dudy after dudy I love you so
much oh you're a gushy whoy you're a
sweet you're a sweet sweet
friend put I have created an astonishing
partnership with aura before we get into
the main meet of the show today I wanted
to take a second to talk about our
sponsor Aura have you ever Googled
yourself and you you are shocked to see
all your personal information is exposed
on one of these public listing sites
we're talking about your name your email
your phone number they got it all or are
you tired of constantly receiving spam
phone calls to the point where you don't
even answer your phone anymore yeah it's
insane and our sponsor Aura can identify
data Brokers exposing your info and
submit opt out requests on your behalf
because gang Brokers are legally
required to remove your info if you ask
them to but they make it super hard to
do so so let Aura handle it for you
they'll do the hard work of keeping you
safe online so you can focus on other
tasks with peace of mind you can either
let people continue to exploit and
profit off of your private information
or you can go to aura.com
dudy
dudy to start your twoe free
trial
all right I mean it borders on Welcome
to the 84th episode of dudy when we
first started this little family a lot
of people said we wouldn't make it they
said one or all of us would be dead by
episode 32 well look at us now breaking
expectations and taking reservations
laying down laws and busting up Jaws
curing common colds and stirring
Rodman's bowls running wild in the sewer
pipes and bearing child when the time is
right speaking of bearing child I have
four precious progyny to sacrifice to
the old gods today first up is little
baby celebrating celebrities next on The
Chopping Block is what is this then I'm
going to bring out happy 35th and you
know we're going to finish it all off
with a brand new segment of the week let
me know when you're ready to start the
flow you you're just giving away that
you've already no I'm not giving it one
of my talking about I don't know what's
going on with no I get it it's your
routine now I get it's good hey it's
good to have a routine you know what I
mean you really you haven't gotten into
Pandora panone Pandora let me explain
this it's a just an Italian cake they
have it all around Europe it's all it's
around South America and here and in
Canada and it's delicious stuff around
the world basically Pandora is just like
it's a big old [__] fluffy ass cake
that the tell you just buy it in a box
you see at the grocery store is like
angel food cake uh it's sort of sort of
yeah that my favorite cake a child this
stuff kind of kind of pulls apart and
gloms together and uh you know in Italy
it's just one of the things and and and
with my Italian family growing up you
you you got to have the Pandora you got
to have the panone after any sort of
Christmas meal and then you just have
with some coffee you can dip it in your
uh cafe latte uh which you you know and
then uh sometimes it has chocolate chips
in it chocolate sometimes it has raisins
nice or you get the Pandora it's just
it's the icing sugar on the outside M
boy Good Eats sounds good hey speaking
of uh speaking of uh hanging out and
celebrating you know uh dude's evening
is coming up of course on uh December
28th you know all about it uh if you are
one of our pods pal of dudy it's that
time right in between Christmas and New
Year's Eve when you're if you're back in
town and you can go and hang out with
your pals and do a little dude's evening
hang on the 28th but things are already
getting a little festive I'm sure you're
out there enjoying the festivities out
in Los Angeles going all sorts of light
shows buying Christmas Tre I I hate
Christmas uh we went to the Grove this
past weekend it was an absolute
nightmare but I will say I already have
your dude's evening present oh what is
it what is it you got to wait you got
wait come on got wait for D evening dude
I'll tell you what we had uh you know uh
this past weekend actually had some of
our uh our good friends came and and
hung out and you did not and you missed
a good time there were a bunch of our
friends there uh not the least of which
was
uh my good pal Marshall joint compound
cook good friend of yours and Cyrus the
Jesse Pinkman of sheit was there and uh
and uh we had a good time and uh I even
oh look at that look at that there's
there they are and we brought the belt
out there's there's Marshall and Si
throwing up size throwing up the the the
wolf pack I see that
yeah a and uh man did we ever have a
good time who who took that picture I
took that picture what'd you take it on
I took it on my C pH thank you well it
yeah I see what you've done it was very
low light oh but the the point is we had
a good time and we brought the belt out
and if you're watching on YouTube see it
yeah we just everyone loves to see the
belt and I'm happy to facilitate that
cuz I'm I'm a champion of the
people
okay [__] we all know you darling little
human beings are fascinated with the
worship of your celebrities and some of
your most prized celebrities have been
up to some very cute things I'm going to
lay it all out for you and I want to
hear what you both think about these
three newsworthy pieces of celebrity
news this is celebrating celebrities
begin celebrating celebrities yeah uh we
did this a while back uh I remember
usually it's a silly uh story or
something that we wouldn't normally I
remember one about Drew Barrymore's uh
crustless pizza salad or something like
this yeah she takes the the the toppings
off the pizza and puts the salad down
and puts the toppings remember EX on top
it became an official food of uh dudy
ball if I'm remembering uh correctly but
I guess we're going to get some
celebrity stories for us to comment on
and you know whatever we'll see Ray
Romano once lost a flashlight and then
found it in his underwear that's right
while visiting Jimmy Kimmel Live the
funny man recalled the her moment he
recently lost the small flashlight he
uses to read in bed at night only to
find it hanging out in the strangest
place possible his underwear the
Everybody Loves Raymond the Alum said
that he understands that there are
things that you could find in your
underwear and be able to shrug it off
like a nickel but a flashlight now
that's a dingleberry of a different kind
what do you think guys is Ray Romano
really a forgetful night reader or was
he trying to shove the flashlight into
his [__] to teach his wife a lesson
about loss
okay what I don't know that what sort of
lesson about loss losing a flashlight
into your [__] I guess is this
real yeah I guess dudes he's saying that
it it that U he found a flashlight in
his underwear yeah well it looks like he
misplaced it I do that too we all do
that where you stick uh your remote into
your underwear and then um it just it
feels like your plastic uh [__] uh made
of plastic and you have a plastic and
metal penis I'm sure like everybody else
no that's kid that I'm I'm joking I'm
being factious of course I don't know
why he misplaced a a flashlight in his
uh that would have been a good episode
though of his show hey honey where's Hey
where's the flashlight I'm Ray Romano
I'm Ray Romano there's a flashlight in
my underwear and then I put it in my it
ended up in my butt cuz I sat wrong when
I went back to my uh went back to my
chair to watch Monday Night Football
that's my flashlight Raymond that's my
Brad Garrett yeah that's really good did
you like that yeah it was really good
Raymond you got to if you're going to
teach your wife a lesson about loss
you've got to put the flashlight into
your butthole literally Robert loia
again it doesn't matter what you tea up
it's Robert Loa I mean that's the beauty
of Loa he's a good base impersonation
for literally anything else my uh
flashlight ended up in my ass and then
uh I I heard someone uh trying to get
into the house and it was a a a home
Intruder so then I uh you know what I
did I I uh he he knocked on the window
and I bent over in fear but then the gas
that I had uh you know loaded up in my
gut and then uh my it was the flashlight
was in my bum just one of those little
flashlights and then it it shot out and
it went through the glass of the French
window into the guy's eye and into his
brain and killed him killed him by
farting a flashlight out of his [__]
was that in the episode or this happened
in real life no this is real life that's
the story I told on on Jimmy Kim damn
Ray Romo yeah that's intense the creator
of Yellowstone Taylor Sheridan is suing
one of the stars of his show over coffee
but that's not all he also kicked the
[__] out of him that's right Sheridan is
suing Cole Hower for trademark
infringement with his rival coffee brand
and they also kicked the [__] out of
each other the second time they ever met
talk about a hostile workplace
environment what do you guys think is
Taylor Sheridan doing the right thing by
suing and kicking the [__] out of his
employees or is this all just a clever
diversion from the alarming number of
fish washing up on the beaches in
Florida with the ability to speak
English huh okay I didn't I've have not
heard that that last bit I haven't heard
about the fish speaking English uh but I
did actually see this headline coming
across some Google news feed or
something I saw the coffee part I did
not know about the beating the [__] out
of each other I remember reading an
article where Taylor Sheridan said
basically like yeah getting in fights
with people is is perfectly fine way to
handle business and interact with one
another I personally don't subscribe to
that I think especially if you're like
the creator of a TV show you should not
ever kick the [__] out of the people
working on your TV show yeah that's just
my take though I I I I I do look look if
I'm being sincere I think it's not uh
it's not uh becoming of a professional
work environment to beat the [__] out of
you're professional actor if you were
working on Yellowstone have you ever
acted in any of Taylor sheron's stuff uh
I have not I you're talking about
Yellowstone 1850 5 1928 1465 2027 99999
111111 if you've been on any of those
shows and he hasn't kicked the [__] out
of you it means you're not doing a good
job you're not doing you're not doing
your job right look uh yeah what I do
know is that uh Cole Hower and Taylor
Sheridan both have coffee brands coming
out and uh and they got into some sort
of dispute I knew that I heard that it
was going uh there was there were going
to be litigious about it they were
having like there's some sort of thing
they're going to court which I guess I
get if it's like no this is based on
this brand and trademark or whatever but
I I will say I think that in a sporting
way if you could somehow settle disputes
um it doesn't need to be with a fist
fight yeah uh although that's kind of
fun out giant Mecca a what in giant
Mecca giant robots that's the premise of
robot jocks yeah a little known movie
from from the uh mid90s one of my
favorite straight to video movies uh
governments solve their quarrels by
putting these pilots in giant robots and
they fight each other for our
entertainment yeah I never heard that
one I never heard of that one robot
jocks we mentioned um uh dudy ball
earlier if you could see now I as you
mentioned I work in Show Business I'm an
actor I mentioned it yeah did you
mention well you mentioned that I'm a
professional acrob tra because you've
never been on a Sheridan show yeah I
haven't done a Sheridan show but you
want to do a Sheridan show I would love
to do a Sheridan show got lot of shows
yeah I've been I've been really enjoying
uh
9999 I'm telling you there is a future
one I think coming out called like 66666
or something like takes place in the
year 66,000 or some [__] I don't [__]
know well uh if if we if you know
sometimes things slow down on set as you
know you're working on something and
there's problems and there disagreements
with you know it's a creative thing
after all people have different ideas if
you just run out the parking lot and
play dudy ball and whip [__] rubber
balls at each other's head uh you things
would happen more exponentially of
course Taylor sharid and uh you know the
show like Yellowstone it's about Gruff
characters [__] uh doing things uh
their own way in big ass uh Ranch Land
Texas Wyoming Wyoming right so uh you
know I guess it makes more I mean you
know it's like when people are on the
military shows and [__] and then they
think they're actually in the military
and stuff y you know what I mean these
guys get out there they feel like yeah
let's punch a cow in the face this is
how George Clooney Rose to power on ER
he said I'm going to play oneone
basketball games against all the other
actors whoever wins gets more screen
time and he'd win them all until Patrick
Dempsey uh beat him at horse was he on
that show no he was on er no he was on
shaa Rimes's show uh uh nurse nurse
nurse people what was that called I
don't know I've been on I've been on an
episode of this show and it's a massive
hit that's been on for 20 years Gray's
Anatomy Gray's Anatomy that's the one
well ER is a different show about other
medical people hold on dude that's you
already did your Robert Lo dude let me
tell you something about Impressions
brother I may not have an impression of
Taylor Sheridan or Cole Hower actually I
do have an impression of Cole Hower okay
uh this is Cole Hower in uh Goodwill
Hunting ready it's a good carwheel
oh it's a good car dude it's a good car
will it's a good car Kelly Clarkson
pisses all over herself in the shower
during a recent episode of her aonomus
talk show Clarkson admitted to letting
the golden water flow virtually every
time she gets in the shower she
explained the warm water is what brings
out the piss and not her love of the
feeling of fresh piss cascading down her
legs the inaugural American Idol
Champion was unclear about whether she
shits in the shower and mashes the turds
down the drain with her bare feet or not
but she made one thing very clear if you
take a shower at her house don't piss or
she will go in there immediately after
you and piss on top of your piss it's
her house what do you guys think is
Kelly Clarkson just indulging in a
little harmless piss play or is she a
Corporal in the army of lizard people
that now control over 80% of America's
daytime talk shows well she's definitely
the latter thing yeah I do think lizard
people are controlling most of America's
daytime talk shows I had no idea uh that
she pisses in the shower on herself
that's why Drew Barrymore wanted to go
back to work without the writer she
doesn't need him CU she's a out of space
lizard yeah uh no I didn't know about
the peeing in the shower eh whatever you
know it's it's sterile you know what I
mean it's pee dude and whatever to each
their own if you like pissing on
yourself or pissing on other people or
getting pissed on great enjoy
indulge uh I personally only take baths
so I would never piss in in the bath
that I'm in no that's that's disgusting
pissing all over your feet is actually
good for uh a A's foot and uh many other
elements I'm sure uh have you ever now
we talk a lot about [__] on this on
this program not a lot but like the
appropriate amount yeah it was something
like 37% of year [__] is something that
literally every human being does every
day unless there's a medical problem but
do you have any good piss
stories nope I got one uh I was
literally just thinking about uh has
nothing to do with uh peeing in the
shower but one time I was one time time
I was on the on the toilet in a in an
airplane yeah and you know I'm [__]
what you're [__] yeah I was [__]
on the toilet I was [__] in the
toilet pardon me on an airplane I've
never [__] on an airplane that seems
horrible are you serious yeah huh well
anyway I was uh making a poo poo in the
airplane and uh I'm a big guy and those
airplane um bathrooms are notoriously
small and I didn't really realize that
when I was uh sitting on the on the
toilet my bum was on the toilet but my
dink was like sort of uh not all the way
in the toilet okay so when I started to
poo I also peed and the pee just went
out onto the floor and then by the time
I noticed it thank goodness it didn't
get on my pants or shorts cuz I a was
just on the floor where those flight
attendants are going to have to clean up
your piss oh not just there Chad it went
all the way to the door and out the door
a little bit oh my god dude and so I
just you know pulled out all the paper
towel yeah that I could and I started uh
you know p uh cleaning up the piss I'm
not Above cleaning up piss or [__] uh
especially my own yeah what do you think
you ever do this you go and you get a oh
sorry you have a story hold on a second
dude you know when you pick up dog [__]
you don't do that no right when you pick
up dog [__] one time Chad was looking
after our dogs for a minute and he said
I if they [__] they [__] I'm not picking
it up but sometimes you pick up [__] and
you end up picking it up another dog
[__] cuz you you can't tell the
difference okay yeah so I'm not above
that and I'm not above uh sweeping up
some piss what happened with your PP
what were you going to say I got so
drunk one time in my early 30s that I
pissed in my own sock
drawer thank you moving on that just
reminded me that that's not even the
worst piss story I have as soon as you
said sockor hey you know what dudy after
dudy I've got a piss story for you in
dudy after dudy and Kelly Clarkson if
you're out there you should really be
tuning in to dudy after dudy obviously
oh man we really are having a good show
today Chad yeah dude yeah dude hey Chad
we're having a good show today I have
created an astonishing partnership with
tushi taking a big dump is great but
dealing with the aftermath not so much
wiping just kind of spreads the Poo
around give yourself the ultimate clean
and turn your bathroom into a personal
Oasis with the refreshing stream of
water coming from your hello tushy bedet
and Chad this thing has changed my life
I tell you what I love the hello tushi
bedet uh like I said before if you're
wiping your bum and you just made a poo
and uh you're just sliding your poo
around uh your your bum hole because you
if you have like a hairless bum hole or
if you have a lot of hair in your bum
hole and you start wiping it's sometimes
like trying to get country gravy out of
a hairbrush but I use the hello tushy
bedet and that way I go all day without
having an itchy [__] hello tushi is
offering our listeners an exclusive
limited time offer 15% off your first
bedet order plus free shipping go to
hellotushy.com
dudy for 15% off all the days that's
hellotushy.com and enter promo code dudy
at checkout
will and Chad I've given this a lot of
thought and unfortunately I have no idea
what in the [__] any of this is I'm
talking about reality here boys can you
help me out and offer your opinions
about what you think reality is cuz I'm
stumped this is what is this begin this
is a great question de cuz I ain't got
no [__] idea either and nobody does
what reality is that's an a what is it
what is this what's any of this that's a
good it is a good question yeah yeah
it's one that no one can answer no one
of our feeble Minds can answer well
that's one thing I agree with you on
Chad nobody nobody uh with our feeble
Minds can answer it shall we attempt to
Yes uh because it's not up to us to move
on no we must attempt to now this is
kind of where I always go in my head
when I think about this question and I
think about this question probably every
day is this physical world is this [__]
real or not real meaning is it a
Hallucination is it a hologram there are
all many many different theories that
have come from the scientific Community
about what the fundamental nature of
reality is string theory M Theory blah
blah blah uh no one knows is the string
theory very sis boom
ba hey everybody we're having a good
time here dude z d d
DZ oh hold on hold on Chad hold on dude
hold on hold on dude I'm trying to do
the fart thing yeah well if you're going
to derail a conversation brother yeah
just don't though let's have this
conversation that was a good one so if
you if you think of it like uh what are
chimpanzees to us right chimpanzees are
have the mental capability of of roughly
like a three-year-old 5-year-old kid
maybe yeah of us yeah there have to be
entities in this
universe to whom we are the the chimp
you know what I mean that can understand
things on a much higher level than we
can and I don't know what the the end of
that is are there any beings any
conscious beings in this universe that
understand reality fully I don't know I
don't think we understand a tenth of it
well you know a lot of people sometimes
you know more recently I've keep I keep
telling people it's like something will
happen or it's a coincidence you'll hear
you know you you'll think of a song you
haven't heard in a while and then you
walk into a store and it's playing in
the in the you know over the system
there or whatever and and I just start
to go like this is a computer simulation
okay so you think that that's possible I
I I I used to not think that it's
possible but then you you look at like
like someone like you know an
astrophysicist like Neil degrass Tyson a
friend of the show sure friend of the
show will say like if there's a 1%
chance that uh we're in a computer
simulation mathematically that means
that there's a 99% chance now I'm not
quoting uh a claimed astrophysicist Neil
degrass Tyson directly cuz I'm pretty
sure he actually didn't say that what I
am saying is if there's even a
possibility then it means
that okay here's what I'm trying to say
please the other day I was uh you know
the actor Jimmy Simpson yeah he's a
great actor uh and uh I was I was
chatting with him I haven't seen Jimmy
Simpson in years okay uh and then I was
chatting with him on the texting yeah
and then I went to the [__] [__] Home
Depot and who was at the Home
Depot who you're not going to believe
it who was it Jimmy Simpson was that the
so why does that [__] happen we are
starting to understand more and more
scientifically about how the quantum
Fields work quantum entanglement all
this kind of [__] information being two
plac at the same time how Consciousness
can affect reality this could have
something to do with it but POS this
question to you you're saying maybe
we're living in a simulation even if
that's the case that doesn't explain
what reality is because the simulation
that we're living in had to have been
created by either another sensient race
or another simulation or an autonomous
AI or something like that and what is
beyond that what is the fundamental
nature of reality none of us can know
this and it's [__] maddening to me
yeah I understand I hear what you're
saying and I'm I'm sort of half joking
about the the the the computer
simulation it's only because as you say
we can't fathom what the hell is what
the hell this all is so we start coming
up with [__] like maybe we're in a
computer simulation computer what the
[__] like that's our understanding of
something a computer that's our greatest
tool you know in a way sure uh D would
of course attest to that uh but that's
just our human mind going here's a weird
invention that we've created uh and now
we're thinking about how uh you know you
simulate and simulate I think that
reality is
uh is I think that reality is connected
to each one of our souls Chad and our
perception let's here I'll I'll run a
little um little experiment with you
right now okay sure
okay I know what I'm seeing when I'm
looking at Chad yeah to me Chad is
wearing uh I see he's got a black hoodie
on he's wearing a black dudy T-shirt
just like me Chad has two eyes a nose he
has a mouth uh I know that his skin
color is that of a what we would
consider to be a a Caucasian person but
watch when I ask Chad what he sees when
he looks at me Chad what do you see when
you look at me roughly the same thing I
mean I am colorblind so I I don't think
that we perceive colors in the same way
in all this but you're you're getting
that kind of debunks what I was yeah
okay so for forget what I said because
that we see each other you need me to
say to finish experiment well I thought
maybe you were going to say oh you're
blue and you have scales and that hat is
alive and the hat has arms and it
reaches into your ears and pulls out uh
ear wax to eat on its mouth because it's
one of those this is just a sucker fish
like on the side of a whale you could
have been saying anything but you didn't
but you're talking about perception
which has nothing to do with reality is
there an objective reality outside of
our perception or not I think there is
but I agree with you every human being's
perception of whatever their experiences
are and whatever reality is is
completely different there is there is
no unified observation of this thing
we're living in there cannot be simply
because we all have different
perspectives even something as simple as
like you're taller than me so you see
the world in a slightly different way
just from like a slightly different
Vantage Point even that is massive but
even beyond that we have all of our
cultural differences all of our
religious views all of our scientific
views that each one of us has some kind
of different way of looking at [__] so
we'll never fully come together and say
we're all looking at the same thing even
though that thing I think is existing in
objective territory objective ter yeah
dude the objective territory dude well
hold on dude I'm talking about the
objective territory dude that was a hard
territory to break into dude yeah dude
cuz Dusty rhods was the booker there
brother and that's right when you saw
iron Claus coming out dude and he had
Carrie and Kevin von Eric come into the
territory dude and then oie Anderson was
booking dude D anyway I don't know you
know I think I think but I look here's
what I I don't you know I don't know
that I know but I do know this we'll
probably understand it and have an
answer by the end of the episode
otherwise okay why would dudy have even
asked this sure we'll have an answer to
objective reality by the end of the
episode of course all
right thank you moving on all right good
sounds like you guys don't know what any
of this [__] is either at least I'm in
good company speaking of company it's
that time of year when you have to start
going to company holiday parties and
there's no better way to show your boss
that you care about the company and the
workplace culture than by arriving at
your company party in one of several
dudy pieces of apparel that you can get
for 10% off right now until Wednesday
December 13th at dudy store.com when you
use the code dudy and more good news if
you order by Wednesday your items will
arrive before dudes even show your boss
who's boss by making them drink piss
from a dudy mug speaking of bosses
here's a clip from Tom hayne's new audio
autobiography about some of the jobs he
had before he became a professional
actor what chapter one Hollywood nights
when I came to Los Angeles I weighed a
buck 25 dripping wet I knew I had to
bulk up fast if I was going to land any
rolls and like most other rubber dicks
Who come out to the City of Angels to
chase their dreams I was flat broke I
wasn't lucky enough to have a rich mommy
and daddy sending me cases of Skittles
like Natalie Portman so I had to take
whatever I could find and I'm not proud
to admit this but my first job in La was
a veterinarian and I was a damn good one
but my heart wasn't in it I quit before
I got my first paycheck and still needed
some way to put on weight fast so I
started [__] the night manager at the
Taco Bell at the end of my street in
exchange for the stale chalupas nobody
bought at the end of the day I gained 50
lb in 2 weeks and book my my first role
as Dr Dalton o' howerin on a little show
you might remember called the Young
veterinarians I won my first Emmy for an
episode in which my character had to
surgically detach Siamese twin beagles a
surgery I performed twice in my short
time as a real veterinarian funny how
life
Works what huh yeah dude to wrote a book
about his his first jobs in Hollywood I
guess no the book was how he became
wizard man yeah I guess this is just
chapter one yeah this is just cuz all
things have led to Tom Hayne becoming
Lizard Man uh wizard man or lizard man
yeah dude uh yeah dude lizard man dude
he was in that territory brother the
Dirty Dutch Manel came in and he had the
book dude and he was like I got Matt
Bourne dude and that was before he was
oh hold on dude that was before he was
dink the clown dude and and Dirty Dutch
was like you're going to be lizard man
dude and then I had to work with lizard
man brother yeah dude um uh uh uh that
was very uh that was really something um
the uh the was anyway hey everybody hey
all right everybody hey this a half time
time hey hey we're halfway between
between the show it's half past the hour
here quarter pass half but the half 30
pass dude hey dude 30 pass you ever see
that will s that Hulk Hogan impression
on uh on dudy you ever see that he goes
like this he goes w d yeah that's what
he does hey got D got D dudes he
everybody go over to the link tree.com
dudy hit the hit the clips B we got the
new clips Channel dude you can get the
new dudes evening Stout whoop psych it
sold out thank you to everybody who
ordered dudes evening Stout everybody
hey everybody we got a new stickers that
go over to Pal pod pal of dudy you want
to go over there get these stickers dude
they Cody halber made a new sticker over
there Pals of dudes.com hey it's a dudes
evening sticker everybody there it is it
Pals of dudes to get that sticker put it
on
put it on y put it on your big bottle
everybody put that put a sticker on hold
on yeah fart noise ugah horn slide
whistle we got some uh comments here
from YouTube everybody please uh go over
to YouTube youtube.com there some
comments subscribe don't forget to
subscribe get you 10% off of the next 24
hours of dooy store then subscribe on
YouTube this one's from woy at woy says
sometimes when my boss is telling me
things I already know I have to stop
myself from saying thank you moving on
that's what D says so that's hot fruit
punch not a good way to drink fruit
punch says Johnny Pupa and chod are the
chaotic neutral characters the world
needs I completely agree this one's from
dick handy on YouTube who says how you
like them apples damn wizard man just
gets better and better I we love the
wizard man we'd like to see way more of
it thank goodness for the autobiography
D this one's from ly 182 says Stone Cold
texting with Tom dong is one of my
favorite things I've ever seen on the
show so far absolute gold that happened
last week this one's very interesting I
think this one is extremely interesting
says this is from mallerie Colbert 1554
who says my husband is a longtime
performative Coffer and now uses will to
justify it solidarity with Chad my God
God hey solidar right back at you what's
the name of this user uh this is
mallerie Colbert mallerie Colbert
solidarity to you to as well uh we are
living tortured
existen it's not all performative
coughing sometimes you just got to cough
yeah anyway we're almost to the segment
of the week but first Die Hard turned 35
this year this is Happy 35th
begin okay okay I guess we're talking
about die hard I like the didn't really
need to drum roll that because dudy
knows dude 35 what I know which is that
my pal CH over here and I we love die
hard I [__] love die hard and it's
kind of a Christmas movie yeah I mean it
takes place at Christmas have seen this
movie at least 100 times at least in my
lifetime the guy who wrote it Steven
daza did a bunch of other like huge
movies in that era I think still is is
around and doing stuff too but he did
like 48 Hours Another 48 hours that [__]
uh those kind of like 80s comedy action
type movies and die hard really spawned
almost like a new genre of somebody
being trapped in a location having to
get out I remember like die hard on a
blank became kind of a yeah a log line
for many movies after yeah man yeah and
the guy who directed it directed
Predator oh yeah predator predor and a
lot of other uh Arnold Schwarzenegger
movies Bruce Willis kind of every man
you know yes dude I remember that you
remember seags gold golden wi cool W and
it's
Dr I take back everything I said about
you uh well everything I said
sarcastically about you being a good
singer and let me just say this Chad
you're a really good singer I see you
win literally into the [__] camera
when you do that something oh D I got
something in my eye um getting better uh
man what else can you [__] say about
uh I remember the glass scene where the
guy shoots out of the glass cuz he knows
that Bruce Willis has on no shoes that's
right and it's like [__] you buddy now
you got to walk and cut up your goddamn
feet there were like there were these
seminal moments in these 80s movies for
me when I was a kid of like kind of
horrible inflicted injuries there was
another one like Rambo do you remember
when he falls through the trees and he
gets a [__] thing and he's got to
cauterize his own thing or like Stitch
himself up he he puts uh the the
gunpowder in there and then he he like
lights it on fire
he's yeah that's what he does and in
this one in this one it's the brilliant
Alan Rickman God Rest his soul Who's
like
Carl shyen
fison shyen
fison something like that he goes shyen
fison right shoot the glass yeah oh
benefits of a classical
education God did you ever watch Harry
Potter nah man I'm not watching that
stuff you know he's one of the main
characters I know he's spliff or snoke
or Coke or what's his name spoff spofy
spiffy splank splan what's his name
Snape Snape I was close look Alan
Rickman is is actually truly uh was one
of my favorite uh professional actors by
trade oh
oh you
know I I know this I know this this is
trippy yeah did you
know okay what now did you know that die
hard playing uh Hans grber yeah in Die
Hard was Alan rickman's first major
Motion Picture role
yeah I think I did know that yeah he
before I mean he was a celebrated stage
actor and had done a lot of uh uh stage
stuff that was adapted for television in
in England and uh had done some TV stuff
but had never been in a movie a big
movie or a I don't think he didn't done
even a movie that [__] that he's one
of the best movie villains in my opinion
he's right up there with uh Mr T in as
Clubber Lang in in Rocky 3
he's because he's he's Justified he's so
well written we know what he's doing and
he's also he's very he's like the
character itself is just perfect for him
he's sort of this classy guy who you
know if you come to him with a with that
he's ruthless he's killing people kill
he kills right in the very beginning
which is great and they don't do any
killing after that but it sets up that
he is a killer he will kill and you are
on this path like if you don't stop him
he will kill all these [__] people
including ex-wife uh Bruce Willis but he
but he there's that guy the the smarmy
guy who's like kind of hitting on Bruce
Willis's wife and and he kills that dude
like cold blood because that guy's kind
of a smarm mey prick right he had it
coming Alan Rickman you can set your
watch to Allan Rickman in that role and
that [__] scene where the American
accent oh yes yes dude see see how my
pal Chow knows exactly who I am dudes a
handshake for that one y he when he goes
no please he runs please don't hurt me
uh it's so [__] good and you're like
oh [__] he caught him the movie's over
you're like 45 minutes into the movie
you're like the movie's over he just
[__] caught the bad guy and then on a
dime just becomes a different person
please don't hurt
me what the [__] he doing and he just
tricks your your hero well we think he
tricks Bruce Willis cuz he pretends to
have an American accent and he's like as
Chad says please don't go any freaks out
he's like hey hey I'm not going to kill
you don't worry I'm not going to kill
you you're all right hey and he's like
uh what's your name and he has some
American name and he's like you know you
ever shot a gun before and he gives Hans
grber a gun and this is why I say Hans
Gruber because the whole time he knows
that it's Hans Gruber and that's the
scene where he [__] takes the gun and
he points it right at [__] Bruce
Willis so now he has confirmation I mean
he already knew but he's like click
clicks the gun and he's like what do you
think I am a [__] idiot and takes a
gun from him just just and uh uh uh
what's his name the fellow who was the
the father in Full House he's really
good the guy who plays the police uh the
chief he has a [__] job in that movie
his stuff is all like Brash and bravado
but says stupid things hey there's no
hostages up there just so that the other
guy can go yeah there are he's like oh
who's that cow boy you don't [__]
know the limo driver in the opening
brilliant super funny it was just like a
perfect movie really uh at the perfect
time it kind of transcended all those
like you're saying it's the Everyman it
wasn't a giant bodybuilder it was just
this guy who was on Moonlighting uh was
going to save the day yeah was that
movie 88 was that 1988 [__] dude I think
86 88 somewhere in there8 to 88 I think
yeah man you know I can't believe it's
35 years old oh that means it's 88 88 uh
unreal an unreal uh movie and one of
those movies that you went to with your
pals when you were a kid and you were
like uh excited to see I wasn't super uh
into action movies necessarily as a kid
well we've talked about that oh my god
dude that's like all I watched I I was a
junkie for it I liked uh comedies and uh
light dramas um as a child no I I mean I
dug all sorts of
you know action and fantasy stuff little
bit of sci-fi but it was really the fact
that Bruce Willis who was it was I
remember it being interesting to me that
Bruce Willis was in this role and uh he
did he did birth a a sort of a genre of
like that every man and it was one of
those movies that I I can't say enough
about it you go home afterwards you go
to the schoolyard and you're telling
everybody about the shoot the glass all
the all the K [__] too that was
like and then in the made for TV uh
version It's yippy Kay Mr
Falcon huh
exactly shyen defis shoot the glass Carl
shoot the GL so many good lines in that
movie yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
the here's the thing I want to tell you
about die hard yeah I went to the I went
to the set of Die Hard you know you were
supposed to be die hard yeah that's
right yeah is that true I don't know
yeah I was supposed to be yeah because
they said it's the same director so I
went to see my friend the director and
on this day Bruce Willis he kills this
guy the first terrorist the blonde guy
with the glasses and then they said Hey
Arnold do you shoot the scene now where
he shows up in the elevator he's all you
know he's dead and he's all choking the
blood everywhere and I said what you
need to do is you need to put right
right on his
sweatshirt I have a gun now I I have a
machine gun now ho ho ho that way you
say the snap equip without Bruce Willis
even being there and they Ed the idea oh
wow yeah in the movie they said you co
writer on die hard yeah yeah I wrote die
hard yeah that's why he's he's wearing
this weather says I have a machine gun
now and then I put it ho ho told him
right ho ho ho it's Christmas movie
because yeah yeah a Christmas that way
you know is a Christmas
movie thank you moving
on now it's time for that savory segment
of the week this week it's a scrumptious
segment indeed will when you told me
your idea for the segment this week I
thought it was perfect Chad pull out
your computer and take us on a Cheesy
crusty s Saucy Journey it's time for
pizza the movie part nine because will
felt like it's been a while since we did
that and he's a good pal to his buddy
Chad Chad you wrote a movie called Pizza
the movie in 2019 I found it on your
astonishing Google Drive and asked you
to read the first two scenes in episode
9 the next two scenes in episode 15 the
next two scenes in episode 20 the next
two scenes in episode 28 the next two
scenes in episode 35 the next two scenes
in episode 43 the next two scenes in
episode 62 and the next two scenes in
episode 75 will you read me the next two
scenes please this is pizza the movie
part nine begin okay now I know what
you're going to say so I say it I guess
tell everybody else somehow this has
become your idea this is a movie I
[__] wrote the entire movie and now
somehow you've stolen this as your idea
for the segment of the week I just I
thought it would be a nice thing listen
hats off to you champ and thank you
sincerely cuz I do love pizza the movie
I'm Happ pza the movie Chad wrote a
movie called Pizza the movie that he uh
wanted to get off the ground with uh uh
Pizza Pizza comp like a big uh Papa John
Papa joh joh Domino whoever wanted to
make it and um and uh it never got made
but but it might still because maybe
dudy will make it well dudy has taking
an interest it's not just me saying hey
dudy do this do that all right I'm
looking through this thing here it do it
through these segments so okay just to
catch everybody up basically the story
of pizza the movie is a high school
delivery or sorry a pizza delivery boy
in high school is delivering three
pizzas over the course of a night one to
the house of a girl that he likes one to
his best friend's house and one to these
criminals there's a mixup and the
criminals start chasing himh um so he
now we are at a point where he has
bested the criminals he is now about to
go to a big backyard party where many
pizzas must be delivered to this party
and the criminals are still kind of
chasing him and he's now meeting up with
the girl that he likes and uh and her
friend at the pizza place now in these
segments I believe there is as I'm
looking through it there's all the
characters you and I normally do JoJo
Grimaldi Allen who is the main character
his best friend Paul uh Tina and laurant
these are the girls that they like but
there's part part well who's these guys
party goers yeah there's some party
goers at this big backyard party which
is being thrown by a character named
Harry
prder and uh there's also a new
character you know uh Elon mickman was
in Harry prer oh I didn't know that yeah
yeah you can be partygoer one I'll be
partygoer two okay and uh I'll be Harry
proter you be all the other characters
that you normally are I'm Allan I think
you're everybody else yeah uh yeah I'm
Paul I'm thank okay and we have one new
character in this yeah it is a police
officer named officer cuner okay okay
and he is in my mind Matthew mccon oh
interesting there's no there's no there
what can you do a mccon well I yeah
everyone can do a MCC all right all
right all right can you do a MCC I think
I
can it's all right it's all right I'm
going to give you your flowers there
it's all right but this is the first
time that a a a name actor is is
suggested in the thing I don't everybody
does that's the thing it's one of those
I was going to say everyone does like a
Matthew mccon and it's kind of a
take-home impression that you're sick
and tired of hearing people do let do uh
have dud you want dudy you want dudy to
do it dudy plays officer computer can
dud yeah dudy should play if that's
possible yeah of course it's possible
okay all right I'm down well why not
because uh I don't want to do it and
you're you you maybe just need to trim
about 30% of the E gross Chad's coughing
away I coughed away from you there was
no performance all right whatever hey D
do you want D will you please read uh
would you like to read uh uh officer
compuer it would be my honor to play
officer compuer in Pizza the movie okay
okay okay [__] dude all right you ready
yeah let's do it Pizza the movie uh dud
is gonna read interior saucy's pizza
night Tina and laurant sit on two stools
at the bar they're surrounded by pizza
boxes everywhere in the place
all I'm saying is that sometimes you can
really judge a book by its
cover but you haven't really even talk
to him that much enough to know I don't
like him she's talking about Paul who
lauron is talking about Paul and Paul
likes a crush on Leon yeah Mr galdi
comes out from the back with one final
pizza box interrupting them he walks
over to a tall stack of pizza boxes and
carefully places the last one on top
there all done now where's Allan just
then the door swings open it's Allen
Paul and Paul's little brother there he
is Alan she gets up off her bar stool
and goes to him it feels like a hug is
coming but they're too nervous instead
they do an awkward dance of half steps
toward and away from each other hey Tina
sorry I didn't get your messages but
thanks for the heads up anyway yeah no
problem I knew those guys were up to no
good yeah they sure were but thanks to
your emergency call We rescued Paul and
check this out he pulls out the $100
bill whoa that's awesome if I had
something like that I'd put it towards a
new rig really yeah I've been saving up
all year I don't need much more but it's
the off season for babysitting right now
and I tried getting a job down at the
orchard but they're all staffed up
before ell can respond to this news J
galdi interrupts them hey kids sorry to
ruin a tender moment but Allan we got a
job to do you ready Allan turns towards
the pizza boxes turns towards the pizzas
then back toward JoJo Grimaldi you bet
Mr Grimaldi in profile we see each of
the two men they stare at each other as
they take in huge breaths expanding
their lungs to their limits then they
lean in close almost nose to nose never
blinking never breaking their Mutual
gaze they recite the
code a pizza ordered is a pizza
delivered he slaps Allen in the face a
pizza delivered is a pizza eaten he
slaps Jo galdi in the face a pizza eaten
is a pizza enjoyed he slaps Allen in the
face two pastas don't make a pizza he
slaps J galdi in the face now let's
deliver more pizza than we've ever
delivered deled they're about to clasp
hands to seal the pack they've made to
each other to uphold the delivery code
together but well I never did see such a
beautiful sight in all my life that's
good dude what the [__] all turned
toward the front to see a police officer
walking in he's in uniform slowly
walking around the pizza box and
surveying them this is Officer
cuner I was just minding my own business
driving down the highway headed back to
the office to call it a night when I
could swear I was smelling pepperoni and
cheese and mushrooms and black olives
and sauce and dough everyone is on edge
what's this pig want I said to myself uh
that would have to be a whole lot of
pizza for me to smell it all the way out
here hell that' have to be a mountain of
pizza to make a smell like that so I
followed my nose and low and behold a
mountain of pizza it's not a crime to
make a lot of pizza
officer quiet let me handle it this the
kid's right the kids's right there is no
statute against making as much pizza as
you want but I'm curious about where
this pizza's
going officer compuer now you know I
can't give out any of my customers
information that's not legal yeah I know
I just well look I'll shoot straight
with you Mr grimal we know there's a
backyard party somewhere tonight chatter
about it's all over the grid we just
want to know
aware I don't know anything about any
kind of party officer we don't want to
stop the party or get anyone in trouble
we just want to make sure everyone's
having fun and getting home safe you
know I actually met my wife at a
backyard party many moons ago officer
computer Smiles wistfully like I said I
don't know nothing about any type of
party officer all right all right all
right I get it no party guess I'll just
pack up and be on my way then he walks
slowly back toward the door finger
tracing a lazy line across the tops of
one of the pizza boxes actually he turns
back around to face Jojo and the
others would you mind if I bought one of
these pizzas might be nice to take it
back for the boys you
know no sale oh come on it's not like
you don't have a few to spare I'll give
you a big tip no sale officer computer
gets agitated up he almost
sad you know what what you did he isn't
right I could smell these damn pizzas
from i43 now you're saying I can't have
one that's not fair Mr Grimaldi and you
know it Grimaldi softens hangs his head
he knows he's pushed it tooo far officer
computer is a good man he doesn't
deserve
this officer hey come on
now I just got a little worked up the
pizza in this room is the biggest
delivery I've ever done and it means a
lot to me you're right though and I'm
sorry but I still can't give you one of
these pies they're bought and paid for
then the apology is
meaningless but what I will do is give
you all three backup pizzas I made in
case some of these didn't turn out
officer officer computer lights up Judo
galdi hands him three boxes of pizza
from behind the counter computer lifts
the lid and inhales deeply eyes rolling
back in his head he comes back to
reality and closes the Box Mr galdi
you're good
[Laughter]
officer computer pizza's family officer
computer heads out the door with his
fresh backup Pizza joro turns to Allen
they stare each other down reenacting
the moment that officer computer
interrupted they clasp hands in the
center of the frame in an arm wrestling
style pose a pose of power exterior sa's
parking lot minutes later JoJo Paul
Paul's little brother Allan Tina and
laurant stand in a long line handing
pizza boxes to each other in a chain
from the store to the back of Allen's
delivery car far uh from far enough away
the Moonlight makes them look like
ghosts doing some secret ritual night
after night completely unaware they died
years ago in this very spot they sing
the tone is somber contemplative
Angelic how do we you all everybody is
singing this so we all have to do it one
two pizza for and pizza for
you e little more pizza for little old
me four five eating pizza all day makes
me feel
more 6 7 my pizza you'll never be
forgiven 8 9 11 Pizza is a perfect slice
ofen exterior Harry PR's house backyard
night the part's in full swing but the
guests don't seem to be having much fun
they stand in small groups looking down
at their feet mostly two party goers
discuss the State of Affairs does this
party seem kind of I don't know light
yeah I can't put my finger on it but
something is definitely missing you want
to bail catch a scary movie or something
sounds good I told my parents I'd be at
the library all night don't want to
waste my freedom my parents think I'm
taking an online c c seminar C sem my
parents think I'm taking an online
seminar that teaches you how to study so
I got the whole night too let's get it
party go number one number two toss
their cups in a nearby trash can and
start to leave the party party interior
Harry PR's house Second Story window
Harry stands in his familiar pose two
fingers separating the blinds as he
looks down from a above at the people in
his backyard he can tell things aren't
going well as he watches the two party
goers we just saw start to walk out no
no no this isn't how it was supposed to
happen where are you Grimaldi ding dong
Harry looks up from the window hoping
his eyes this backyard party isn't over
yet interior Harry Potter's House uh
foyer by the front door same Harry
bustles hustles through a few groups of
Meandering party goers as he makes his
way to the front door out of my way move
it he finally gets to the front door and
opens it to find Allan Tina Laurent Paul
and Paul's little brother with giant
stacks of pizza boxes Allan flashes his
best smile got a delivery for a backyard
party is this the place Allan opens the
Box he's holding Harry leans in closes
his eyes and inhales deeply yeah oh
[Applause]
yeah thank you moving on thank you D was
un [__] believable that was
incredible absolutely incredible officer
computer has never sounded as good in my
head gee whiz okay well was exactly what
it needed to be no more no less let that
sink in and let 92 points sink in
because that's exactly what you boys
take home today congrats now you got got
7,888 overall that's 2,112 points to go
before you get rocked by 10K last week
you watched the original Wily Wonka and
the Chocolate Factory with a Daft Punk
soundtrack and I made that watch along
available on dudy Plus at patreon.com
dudy this week it is my absolute
pleasure to ask you both to go see Wonka
on opening night and if you wouldn't
mind would you wear your little hats and
take some pictures for me pretty please
and while you're there please remember
shalam is Wonka thanks to everyone for
joining us this week until next week
call me dudy holy [__] I mean I kind of
knew that was going to happen but go not
because I talked to D but because yes on
dudy plus patreon.com dudy we watched
the original Willy Wonka with Jean
Wilder along with a playlist by dudy of
Daft Punk hits and uh that was a fun
experience you can go check out but now
we're going to go we're go we got to
wear the Wonka hats what do you say I'm
in dude this is going to be fun as hell
I never thought that I'd be this excited
to see a a movie that I had if if it
weren't for D this thing would have
justed yeah and now I can't wait to see
shalam as Wonka because uh Chad I don't
know if you knew this but uh shalam is
Wonka shalam is Wonka
[Music]
[Applause]
peace on
Earth can it
be all right everybody it's dudy after
dudy you know it's that different part
of the
show [__] cuz it's after the show well
dude those are different times brother
you got hold on Chad you got before and
then you got after dude but either way
dude it was uh what was that Territory
called objective territory yeah dude
it's the objective territory so we're
going to get into it we're going to hang
out thank you so much for joining us on
the show and we would love for you to
continue to join us at patreon.com dudy
Dy Dy and we're gonna have a good
[__]
time welcome to dudy after dudy the
flagship weekly show of dudy plus only
at patreon
/dy you boys keep making my job hard but
these are good problems to have I'm
going to go try my best to figure out
who's going to walk away with the belt
today in the meantime relax chill out
get your grooves on this is dudy after
dudy get real with it my
boys I'll get [__] real with it dude
uh this week my [__] got bombarded by
people sending me a link to something
that made me do something I've never
done before in service of my uh
blossoming wrestling fandom holy [__]
[__] what was
it please tell a friend then
rap if you like d what you
do please tell a friend then
rev if you like d here what
you please tell then